Donald Trump's tax returns are going
public on Friday
it's finally happening we already know
much of what is in those tax returns
thanks to the report issued by the
January 6 committee but we're getting
them the tax returns are going to be
released Friday and it's going to be
wild NBC news reporting Trump tax
returns to be released to the public on
Friday
the Ways and Means Committee voted last
week to make six years of Trump's tax
returns public
um this was a party line vote initially
the plan was to release the documents as
early as last Wednesday
the disclosure was delayed due to having
to redact personal information like
Social Security numbers the assortment
of six years of Trump's personal tax
returns and some of his business returns
are expected to be placed into the
Congressional Record Friday
the clock is ticking for the committee
which will turn over control to
Republicans when the new Congress is
sworn in next week
another report from Reuters former
Republican president Donald Trump's
redacted tax returns will be made public
on Friday the documents to be released
Friday are expected to include Trump's
tax returns between 2015 and 2021 the
years he ran for and served as president
a spokesperson for Trump declined to
comment Trump was the first presidential
candidate in decades not to release his
tax returns during either of his
campaigns for president
so beyond the Trump aspects of this what
are we going to learn from the Trump
aspects okay we've gone over it so many
times he's not as rich as he claims to
be he has sketchy debts that raise
questions about being compromised in
National Security he uses this uh some
would call it fraudulent technique of
inflating the value of assets when he
wants to use the asset as collateral for
a loan but diminishing the value of an
asset when it's for the purposes of
figuring out how much attacks he's going
to owe on that answer oh there's the
Trump aspect to it we already learned
most of those things are true from the
summary the house released and we will
get I believe beyond a shadow of a doubt
confirmation from the tax returns
themselves beyond that there are banks
that will maybe end up under pressure
after these tax returns are released to
know from people wanting to know from
those Banks why did you keep loaning
this guy money
when his finances were clearly bad how
did you accept this valuation for a
building that was serving as collateral
when it so clearly was not the value of
the building so I believe there's going
to be attention on Banks and whether the
banks were sort of like look the other
way or whether the banks were complicit
in what some would call a fraud
um we are also going to see potentially
the argument made that you know
something is partisan and biased here
because there has never been this much
attention about any president's tax
returns the right is going to say you
know this is all a politically trumped
up witch-hunt way to go after Donald
Trump because you've never seen so many
people waiting for the tax returns of
another president well no other
president
refuse to release their tax returns and
then worked for six years to prevent
their release that's why there is a
spotlight on this
and they will claim the problem is that
people are eager to see the tax returns
now the reason we're even in this
situation is because Trump did something
nobody else has done
which is to say I'm just not going to
release them now he did say I will
release them once they're no longer
being audited but they weren't being
audited and you all know the lies but
the point here is what's unique isn't
that the tax returns are coming out it's
that they had to come out via this means
because Trump refused to otherwise
provide them so don't fall for that when
we certainly hear from Republicans you
know this is political partisanship
because Democrats are excited about the
tax returns no it's Trump who did the
thing nobody else has done